[Music]
all right i have this story here
that comes from rural alaska
rural say rural rural rural
i don't think you're supposed to
enunciate it like rural rare
serious in rear alaska
yeah i never say that word that often so
i'm like let me just announce
what i just call like country what is
the definition of
like rule bum [ __ ] oh yeah undeveloped
maybe
the boonies i can't even you know at the
moment
basically anywhere that's not nice
[Laughter]
if you don't got a sugar fish you rule
yeah
i still haven't eaten there yet oh
you're rural then i am i ain't lying
mm-hmm they deliver they do yeah i saw
the boxes are pretty cute
oh yeah there's instructions on branding
is on point
all right so in alaska there's this
really remote community
and the whole thing is remote a real
remote
alaska is a remote state yeah it's by
itself next to canada true
so there was this it's closer to russia
than america
there's this one instance at uh during
the night time where
a neighbor heard this really loud sound
outside of her home
she was like doing a sauna or something
and
and so that's when she was like wait
what the heck was that that's a plane
what the heck
something must be wrong a plane like
planes do not fly around
that's how far it is yeah oh that's what
rural means
yes no plane i heard of those
it was 11 30 at night and that's when
she was a late plane ride so she hopped
on her atv
oh [ __ ] now that's a real [ __ ] she's
[ __ ] rude
the definition of hers is really getting
because you're getting real
i was why she didn't hop on her donkey
she hopped on her sled
yeah oh yeah there we go i hooked up my
16 huskies
yeah so then she sped a few hundred
yards to the airport
wow and then that's when there was a
local
pilot who was assessing the problem that
was happening here so
apparently the runway lights weren't
turning on
and usually a pilot can turn on the
runway lights from the aircraft
wow but that had failed too and also
it failed like turning it on manually
from the ground oh [ __ ]
so that's when this one particular
neighbor
the lady that went on her atv she she
ended up calling
her neighbor and that's like 10 miles
away
yeah so then um oh actually the neighbor
called her
to find out when the plane was going to
land that that means
nothing happens everyone's just about yo
where's the plane
there's a plane it's the most exciting
thing
like i'm concerned what is going
what does on know about this plane so it
turns out like once she talked to the
neighbor
she told the neighbor the problem like
oh my gosh the lights aren't working for
the runway this plane can't land like
they can't see
so that's when she took her own car and
had the headlights
illuminate the runway and she told your
neighbor like get everyone
get everyone's ass over here we need all
seven of us need to illuminate this
village so then her neighbor made 32
calls
to 32. not six okay yeah 32 calls
so then that's when every like the
neighbors around
from ages eight to get an eight-year-old
driving a pickup truck and just
bring their power wheels out with the
lights on so about
20 vehicles came within 20 minutes wow
and like i said drivers ranging in the
age of 8
to 70. they were all there they lined up
and they lit up the runway for this
plane to land because
there was a there was a child inside
this plane
and he was flying it no no that's all
the reason they gave a [ __ ]
no it was to save the life of this child
because this child needed medicine
this was like an adult like [ __ ] it wait
okay so the child needed medical
attention it's a medical like so it's a
medical
aircraft yes it is exactly oh and so
that's when all the neighbors came
and they they just lit up the runway
with their headlights
oh wow and they were able to safely land
the plane so was somebody in the plane
had access to the person down
down so they were able to talk yeah
somehow
exactly so these [ __ ] lights won't
turn on
yeah and they just kept like circling
and they're like okay things wrong
so that was true that's what i was
trying to figure out so like how did we
know from here to lighting there
in 20 minutes they were able to figure
that out that's dope they worked really
quickly
but yeah it was life meditating yeah it
was like one guy just trying to
turn the lights on on the on the ground
so here's what happened
so back in may in early may
the lights were damaged over the winter
by
oh wait no in the winter the lights got
damaged from the snow removal equipment
and so the contractor operating that
equipment ended up damaging the lights
so then
they went in early april to try to
correct that damage after like the
the sun i mean the snow had melted and
stuff
but the lights were knocked over and
then they
discovered that there was wiring
problems and so they had to wait
even longer for the ground to thaw out
and so
that's the reason why the lights weren't
working and why do you want to live in
alaska pay you maybe
for the salmon oh they probably got good
because they don't need nobody
have you ever seen the living in the
wild like the peop the shows when they
live in alaska they love it
they are happy i think i would love it
too they are happy
i like watching alaskan gold miners just
imagine knowing
you're the numbers of 32 of your
neighbors right i
don't know the person living down the
hallway all i know is that they keep
[ __ ] being loud at night
they're loud there's 70 people in this
village
that's cool i don't like knowing people
like that and they are
280 miles away from the nearest hub city
holy [ __ ] that's far well it was crazy
when you were like she got our atv and
drove
a few hundred yards to the nearest
airport but they got bears and stuff
yeah i like that i don't know here too
but they got polar bears
and grizzly bears right and you could
vlog both of them
i'm not quite built for that but i know
plenty of people who love that i have an
aunt who lives in alaska cool
not that not in that area maybe like
anchorage
yeah i think yeah i want to go to alaska
i'm going to live
in the north pole which is apparently in
alaska
oh i was like what wait it's not santa's
house
wait wait wait wait wait wait how's that
possible yeah i feel
so stupid right now now the poles in
alaska we've been
we've had the north pole in the the
united states has had the north pole the
whole time
so that's what she says right remember
she told us like this yeah
girl she's super sweet so adorable she
does makeup
she's super cute i'm only gonna she
tells me she lives in the north pole and
i was like
what the [ __ ] where's the north pole and
she was like in alaska and i'm like
is that just the name of the city or is
this legitimate maybe it's the name of
the area
they're probably like it's [ __ ] cold
this is called the north pole i thought
the north pole
was its own little ice cap on the top
yeah and santa lived there city in
alaska
north pole north pole but is but is it
the north pole i don't think so it's too
south you know what i'm saying like
is it oh everything's stopped from the
north pole
oh it says currently no country owns the
north pole
so the actual north pole okay so that
was america's way of like no we're
claiming the north pole we're making our
own [ __ ] right that's all like
we all ain't been to santa's house yet
yeah so there's two of those
she told me like yeah i live in in the
north pole so i'm like
that people live there i went to santa's
village there's a bike park there it's
right here
in arrowhead california i know i went
there when i was a little girl
and they closed it for a really long
time oh really yeah for like well he's
there i see him
summer santa's there yeah he'll say he's
wearing
summer santa claus overall just some
homeless guy
huh just some homeless guy walking no
he's there they're all in character too
does he have a santa
i don't know no there's a place called
santa's village telling a real story
it's
i had to double check i don't know even
though i've been there i don't know
there is a place called santa's village
yeah they got little trains that you can
sit on and they take it's so [ __ ]
cute is it oh yeah
but there's also a bike park there like
you can ride your bicycle
the only reason why i still know is
because i have like
like physical photos of when i went
there i was seven
so you know i'm not lying i sat on
santa's lap
what does your what does your son know
about santa i don't think he knows that
he even
exists yet okay because we'll take him
to like a little christmas things and i
don't think he's like really
fascinated with that kind of stuff just
yet he just likes uh planets and
volcanoes right now
dinosaurs was he like dinosaurs yet he
really liked dinosaurs when he was like
uh one or two but i think it's he
outgrew it and that's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
from now planets yeah
planets and volcanoes and volcanoes and
lava he loves lava
so do you guys have a whole bunch of
planet things yeah
that was his birthday theme all the
balloons were like planets oh
you can name like the whole solar system
on the planet you should get the app
so you could see the planets oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
oh it's real time like if you go like
this i have it on my phone right now
see all the consoles i'll show you he
loves yeah he loves that [ __ ] you should
tell him don't tell him like santa's i
think
they said money believe in money instead
no you save money
you save so you don't have to buy them
gifts and stuff believe in money believe
in money
well actually i i think i like him
knowing that the president came from me
versus some random dude
but isn't it fun though to lie and play
these games yeah
yeah you might throw it back in your
face in the future and be like you
robbed me of like
understanding i mean but now but by that
time them kids are so damn smart they
got phones they can google it
that's know makeup oh [ __ ]
by age five yo 21 like think about all
the babies born now and then when
they're 18.
they know everything that's true you
can't lie look
that's why you're looking at planets
right now you're looking at planets yeah
the moon and mars is right here
right here right around here
isn't that cool what am i like you are a
bull
yeah no legit you're taurus you're a
tourist tourist is around there
yeah oh that means it's night on that
side of the earth right there is mario
wait aren't you a tourist i'm a tornado
sitting here oh there wait where's the
pisces i'm a
there's a fish swimming up something
yeah that's me i'm a pisces all the
constellations
you're a leo makes sense oh
yeah we're soul mates dude all right
what are you doing i don't believe in
that stuff really huh
i play this little thing oh it's so
[ __ ] like girls believe it so learn
about the constellation
it's a good way to be like no way yeah
they're like they're like
oh you're like whenever they talk about
i'm like oh no no i'm so into it that's
right
that's why you knew you're like i'm a
leo you could totally be like but i'm
not like all leos
that's all you need to say and they'll
be like oh my god really tell me about
yourself really does that that's that
line not work on you girls
some girls are really into us some
people let's rephrase it some people are
really into astrology yeah
i feel like they feel like dumb [ __ ]
yup stupid
i know enough i'm like i know enough
about it to hold a conversation that
sounded
to me in my head i'm like that just made
you sound dumb what
wow planets and the stars are there
versus horoscopes constellations
horoscopes astrology
astrology
they used to be used astrology used to
be used for like
um determining health and [ __ ] back in
the day like way back in the day but now
we've got
[Applause]
we have iphones we don't have slingshots
no more i don't know what is your slime
i don't gotta shoot at my foot to guess
use your usual things
because i don't i was like i really
don't know anything i know enough to
have a conversation but not enough to be
like this
enough to have a couple girls that are
super into it oh like i could guess it
they'll name
20 different things yeah right and then
after that i'll be like i knew it i'm
like no
you said the whole thing everything but
leo that's why i was like i'm just
[ __ ] with you i'm a little [ __ ]
scorpio i knew it your mom was a freak i
knew it
you know what my dad said she don't do
what she used to do so i'm assuming so
my parents are my parents that's funny
that your dad talks to you about that
my dad was called he calls himself the
first door-to-door [ __ ]
cause wow used to like he goes all the
like ladies that used to work my dad was
my dad was six too with green eyes and
like tan skin my dad is
my dad's pretty mm-hmm and he likes the
original jason maman
exactly that's where he gets it from
that's where jason but my dad was like
way more like
way more like fitted yeah way more yeah
jason's rugged yeah my mom was like your
dad is such a pretty boy
yeah and you're like where my dad is
pretty is he he is pretty i was like my
dad is pretty
i got good looking parrots
you